democrats in the media looking like
complete fools after falling for another
massive hoax jesse smilet's now a proven
liar after the con artist was convicted
of five of six charges for staging his
own hate crime and then lying to police
about it it was clear to any sensible
person from the start that the facts of
this hate hoax just didn't add up
but that didn't matter to the media
trying to push a racial narrative just
to divide the nation
i don't like that it's being put out
there in the media that this is a
possible hate crime a lot of questions
in this case but i know jesse smallett
is a really really good guy i just want
justice to be served in this case and
the media has really cast so much doubt
on his story which i find so personally
offensive he's given a detailed account
an account that chicago police have said
has been consistent he hasn't changed
his story they also said it's credible
police have said that and also that he
has been very
cooperative
this is america in 2019
and democrats were even worse biden said
homophobia and racism have no place on
our streets kamala harris called it a
modern day lynching and the rest of
their democrat minions were eager to
fall in line
after pushing this fake news the white
house now says wasn't a big deal because
everybody was doing it watch
there are lessons learned perhaps for
everybody who commented
at the time including former president
trump we respect the jury's decision
lying to the police particularly about
something as heinous as a hate crime is
shameful you know if you look back at
the time it's also true and important to
note that accusations of hate crimes
should be taken seriously and they need
to be fully investigated but that's
where everybody was looking at it at the
time
he keeps president trump of falling for
the hoax i know i'm sitting in my office
today which is between you jesse and you
greg and amid all of the noises first of
all we're sorry yes i thank you because
i hear you guys a lot well you more than
craig i will say you can hear me for a
minute i can hear you oh i snoop on your
conversations ask johnny oh boy yeah um
so i'm i'm looking i'm trying to
concentrate and i hear what i think is
the hottest take which is shameful
stelter which i can't wait to hear the
stelter jokes on gutfeld shameful
stelter says oh the right's going to use
this as an example of why not to trust
the media then i hear the hotter take
from jensaki this is all trump's fault i
mean who says this meanwhile her boss is
the ultimate race baiter we've heard him
any number of issues you know let's put
them they'll put uh mitt romney will put
them back in chains remember he told a
crowd the shameful you ain't black
comment and then the shameful accusation
of this jessie smollett crime only to be
surpassed by kamala harris who said this
is modern day lynching along with cory
booker uh not trump's fault sorry yeah
harold she's trying to spread the
gullibility around like it was everybody
that had fallen for the hoax no it was
pretty much every big name politician on
the left and left-wing media figure
that's why you have that's why you have
trials uh when the the allegations came
about they were explosive they were
divisive they were
anybody would be touched at their core
if this was true turned out not to be
true no one should now defend this i
think there are actual attacks based on
someone's sexual orientation their
actual attacks people being attacked
based on race and even gender
this effort here by this this young man
whom i don't know
i don't know why he did it what would
make him do it but it certainly it it
besmirches and makes it casts doubt even
more so on some people who may not be
inclined to believe that hate crimes
actually take place so this made it you
know at some level i think at his core
he probably
wants to to try to advance equality and
and help the country move forward on
race and and gender issues and sexual
orientation issues but he shoved us back
here and anyone that doesn't say this
was wrong
and the jury spoke and he'll face the
consequences
is not doing right by those in this
country who want to ensure that people
who of color people who have a different
sexual orientation are protected yeah
you hurt race relations in the country
and to harold's point
any time another i guess allegation of a
hate crime you see out in the tv people
are going to scratch their heads
because this was so high profile it
raises doubt every time going forward uh
not if you send a message of of sending
jessie smallette to the house gal for a
little spell we might not see a lot of
more hoax in the next couple i i am not
kidding like justice mollet learned to
exploit and inflame racial tensions for
his own personal benefit and gain from
the very people you just showed on the
tv
and what he did was
so he could get a year or two a
first-time offender would get probation
but he committed perjury this is
according to andy mccarthy so he could
go away for a couple of years in fact
but what he did was he pushed and
peddled to hoax designed to rip a
country apart that was already tearing
at the seams he threw kerosene on
already a burning fire so i'll call him
a civil unrest arsonist he was perfectly
happy to see chicago
uh the murder capital of the country and
even the rest of the country besieged by
violence go in go up in flames descend
into riots and for what because he
wanted to maybe play a superhero in a
marvel movie or get a deodorant
commercial
because his talent as an actor wasn't
enough to get him well anywhere anymore
and that's that's what we see social
media makes it so easy to now fall for
these hoaxes you see something and then
the politicians think they have to tweet
about it right away they have to get the
message out there instead of just
waiting just a couple beats you know i
think you've got
i still believe jesse you know i do i do
and i do think that he and maybe o.j
should get together to do a reality show
and find the real attackers yes right i
think that would be perfect too uh what
what uh shinseki when she brought up
trump as an example that really isn't
what we were talking about what we're
talking about we're not talking about
like you know uh saying that the if this
act is true it's bad
it's that the the pressure to silent any
dissent or skepticism as the crime
unfolds so everybody's terrified of like
when you see okay when you hear about
this crime it's so absurd so on the nose
so comical that you burst out laughing
about all the the all the elements it's
like a perverse christmas tree of
twisted ornaments none of it makes any
sense but if you said that during that
week you could be called a racist and
like dagon was saying you know this was
a volatile climate
at the time of the hoax so what he what
he was basically saying was that he was
happy to cause injury perhaps uh
property damage riots whatever
because in order to do the story he had
to have known that this could have some
serious consequences for a lot of
communities and you got to remember like
what uh you know in the three weeks that
this happened i mean in the three weeks
from the start which i think was january
29th to february 22nd 18 people were
killed in chicago including a
one-year-old
and um you have to wonder how many cops
could have been dealing with that and
saving lives instead of devoting all
this time chasing down these imaginary
attackers because they were supposed to
i don't care about smolette i care about
the media uh they're just as guilty
because they they they primed
they primed the their peers the
friends in the media and other and
activists to believe that this was
actually possible that like yeah there
are these mega
man trump supporters yelling maggot
country at one am no one would believe
that unless they were psychologically
primed and we spent five or six years
being primed generally from cnn who was
who had been creating this atmosphere
that was anti-police that this that the
country was systemically racist so you
need two things to to create this
gullibility prime them and you want the
story to be true that's what that's what
happened here and there's and you have
to one last point
it's only one way it's the traffic
towards these folks is only one way
there's there's no moderates there's no
conservatives there's no libertarians
that fell for this
right it was only the left and it's
because the left has been indoctrinated
into the idea that this is a hopelessly
racist country full of evil white trump
supporters who just want to chase
anonymous actors they don't even know
who the guy is
jesse's family doesn't even know who he
is yeah like the maga supporters watch
empire i was always wondering if they
actually had captured it on the
surveillance tape
we would have seen that it was fake
right yeah like we would have seen two
guys dress like yeah what you think like
pulling punches they were it's you know
don't hire two black guys to play two
white guys
i learned that in that casting it's very
important
but i don't think most democrats thought
when his trial started that he was
interested
that's three weeks period you're right
but i think after that i mean i'm a
democrat i don't think they did well
that's why they're silent now
well he almost didn't get prosecuted kim
fox dropped the charges right so he
almost and there are a whole bunch of
clips and tweets about justice has been
done when kim fox originally dropped the
charge
right but there were democrats who put
webb in charge or democrats in charge in
chicago and illinois so just i'm only
saying look i don't disagree why did kim
drop the charges she got a phone call
from michelle obama's ex
that's right remember that i forgot
about
it
all goes back to the obamas everything
way to blame obama jesse could be part
of obama gate it could be part of the
find out
you want me to write that down please
write it down hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else